اعلنت لجنه الوسطاء والحكماء بولايه شمال
دارفور استئناف حركه الشاحنات التجاريه
عبر الطريق القومي بين عاصمه الولايه
الفاشر والخرطوم جاء هذا بعد توقف عندما
اكثر من 16 يوما بسبب الاشتباكات بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بحسب وكاله
السودان الرسميه للانباء سونا شهدت محليه
ام كدادا شرقي الفاشر خلال الايام الماضيه
تكدس عشرات الشاحنات التجاريه القادمه من
الخرطوم الى دارفور والمحمله بمختلف انواع
السلاح الاستهلاكيه
واوضح المتحدث باسم لجنه الوسطاء والحكماء
التي شكلها الوالي بغرض تطبيع الاوضاع
بالولايه ان بورصه الفاشره التجاريه
استقبلت امس نحو 23 شاحنه واشار الى انها
ستستقبل المزيد من الشاحنات المتجهه الى
مختلف ولايات دارفور خلال الايام المقبله